hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today i'm going to be
leaving the hotel room that i have been
locked in for the last 14 days straight
seriously i've not stepped foot outside
that door even one time
and uh it has been quite a journey um
some things that i definitely didn't
expect some things that i
wish i had known coming in that i will
share here um
and i figured i would make this video in
part uh well actually
largely for australians who might have
to go through the same thing
or anyone in any other country you might
have to go through a two-week quarantine
though obviously it varies from country
to country
um but i do want to say before we start
here today that i do already have one
video that was from
like my second day in quarantine that
really does go over probably majority of
the details you need to know majority of
the questions that you might ask
majority of the questions people have
asked there are some things that i've
learned that i can go over
now and first is the checkout process
i have this uh lovely little wristband
that's just been put on me by um
i would guess a nurse a police officer
and someone in a military uniform
who just knocked on my door actually
while i was showering they kept knocking
and i had to be like i'm in
i'm in the shower then they came back
and uh
had a great conversation while i was at
a towel it was not awkward for anyone
um but yeah i've been given this covert
19 new south wales wristband
with the uh marker on here saying i'm
allowed to check out in the am
um on monday so
that's it's i didn't i didn't know that
that would be part of it and it
certainly does feel very strange so
this whole experience has sort of been
like i've been in a hospital in a weird
way with
uh nurses calling me every day to see
how i am
uh two covered swabs again from like
three nurses who have a car to just come
to your room and tell you to stand up
against the door and covered swab you um
but i did also get some paperwork today
on the checkout so i'll just go
through the checkout stuff before i talk
about the entire experience
ahem we have a new south wales state
emergency operations center form
this is confirmation of my completion of
quarantine period the quarantine period
was completed at the novotel darling
harbour sydney new south wales
it basically certifies that i was
clinically assessed
on a date before leaving isolation as
being without a fever and without signs
of respiratory
uh tract infection um i am satisfied
that the client has agreed to completing
a day 16 swab on zero two zero six
twenty one so that is a thing that i
only learned today
is that on the second of june uh i would
have read that date backwards for any
americans who are watching
i have to have another covert test um i
don't know that i'm supposed to submit
information for that anyway it doesn't
say anything about
that um it's just something that they
ask you to do but yes once you leave
two days afterwards you are supposed to
get a covet test
some information about returning home
after isolation
um there are financial and support
services
which is for anyone who can't afford to
pay for the hotel i imagine i have still
not paid i think that i will do that
upon checkout i don't know how much
money i owe them i think it's about 2500
but i'm not actually sure so to the part
where we discuss
kind of some of the things that i've
learned um to give you an overall review
i would say i largely had a totally fine
experience to be very subjective i'm a
person who doesn't get bored very easily
and
i'm very anti-social and introverted so
i was actually never super worried about
me being alone in a room for 14 days it
was not difficult for me
at all um all i really did was work
uh which was entirely on american hours
i was starting between
three and five a.m every day and then
working um i actually kind of split my
day up in half which was really fun for
me i was working sort of like
five to maybe ten and then i would take
a break for several hours and then i
would work a little bit more in the
afternoon because my colleagues are
already asleep
so i was kind of like doing my writing
in the afternoon having my meetings in
the morning that was actually wonderful
for me
i really have enjoyed it having a big
break in the middle of the workday
um it did mean that i was going to sleep
pretty early waking up pretty early
a big plus side of that was getting to
see the sunrise every morning was really
nice but the hotel
i think i did say this in the last video
allows you to get
food delivered um based on your time
zone
so they knew that i was working on
american time and were okay with me
getting food delivered based on the time
zone uh which was really helpful they
also delivered me a coffee every morning
at 7am which was
the nicest thing in the world like
knowing that you're getting a coffee a
cappuccino and a good cappuccino
delivered at 7am was wonderful so
mentally this whole thing outside of
some of the issues that i'll get to um
was very very very easy for me and i
think anyone who's similar to me who
just works a lot you know i made more
youtube videos in the last two weeks
that i think i've ever made before
um that's obviously a big part of it we
did several hours of streams
raised ten thousand dollars for charity
which is incredible
basically i had so much to do that that
the being alone in here part wasn't a
problem
um i did make sure that i worked out
every day using my oculus quest to 2
largely beat saber and fit xr so yes
mentally keeping myself entertained
video games streaming youtube content
work
all day every day um obviously got a lot
of phone calls from my family
and my partner so i was you know still
talking to people quite frequently
almost too frequently for me it's
at some points i had to say this to my
mom i was like everyone's worried about
me being locked in here but you guys
are forgetting that i'm really
anti-social anyway so i'm spending so
much time talking to people
that it's like almost too much a couple
of things that i learned over the period
of time that were
like very very minor downsides you just
kind of get dirty when you're in an
environment for two weeks
you just like there's like bits of
crumbs on the floor or marks from where
i've left this
vanilla coke can which by the way i
ordered through ubereats successfully it
was all good
things feel like they're getting dusty
you know just like stuff just
started to get just like kind of dirty
and i didn't really feel like there was
anything i could do about it
for trash specifically for the meals
they deliver the three times a day which
are all in just these bags that they
give you you just put that back outside
the door you know put your mask on open
the door just throw them out there and
then come back inside
and someone will come around and pick it
up um so i was doing that frequently but
yeah definitely just like wish i had
packed
some kind of wipe i don't know if you
just wipe stuff down
and that ties directly into my biggest
issue with being in here
i'm a person who is uh conscious of
things being dirty
because i have pretty bad asthma um
i think that any like notice of dirt
makes me go oh no is this going to stop
me from breathing and it's been like
that for a while so i'm just very
conscious of that kind of thing
and this is the part of this that
affected me the most negatively um
which i guess i have to disclose because
some gentlemen got very very mad at me
um
for not saying this let me find this
comment real quick so this comment from
bastian de la fuente says unbelievable
tens of thousands of people
are dying or watching their family
member die because of clothes some will
never be able to see their moms or dads
but this woman complained about doing a
quarantine because she traveled abroad
dude be happy you have the option to
travel and see your loved ones
and then he used to like spongebob meme
capitalize
uncapitalized and said i have trouble
breathing [ __ ] please
um so yes i am very aware that i am
extremely privileged
to have been able to come home um to
have you know it's been a year and a
half to see my family again i'm so
excited i know that i'm gonna cry it's
gonna be
amazing for me and i'm definitely aware
that i'm really lucky to be able to do
it because it is really expensive and in
a lot of places like even
harder um to fly to australia from i had
to fly direct from
la to sydney i couldn't fly to my home
state of queensland um
because they didn't have any direct
flights and they advised me not to stop
in any other country so
it can be even more difficult you know
so yes i acknowledged my privilege and
also that i made this choice
and knew that i would be locked in hotel
quarantine but i
want to add having asthma is pretty [ __ ]
and has been a really really negative
part of this experience for me
not in a way that's like oh you can't
breathe shut the [ __ ] up um in a way
that like
you know your lungs are suffocating you
from the inside out so i wanted to talk
about this largely for other asthmatics
to give them the heads up
i always get asthma in a hotel room it's
really common for me sometimes it's
because of dust sometimes it's because
of cleaning products when i'm at home i
have to make sure that i use organic
cleaning products because anything that
is more extreme than that will give me
asthma and i'll have a really bad time
uh hotel rooms are always bad
but before i got here i didn't know that
i would not have any fresh air
so i didn't know that i wouldn't be able
to open a window i didn't know
that i wouldn't be able to maybe go for
a 15-minute walk because i know that's
the thing that um some other countries
have allowed
where you can schedule a time to go get
some fresh air i didn't know there would
be no
option for balconies so i've had asthma
all day every day i even feel out of
breath
speaking right now my laughs have
wheezers in them um
it's the longest sustained amount of
time that i've had
asthma had asthma sure i have asthma all
the time it is a condition that i always
have
but when i say oh i have asthma right
now it essentially means like a really
uh sort of sharp tightness in your chest
you just feel that your lungs are just
smaller than they should be because
they're suffocating you
for some reason and um that is different
to having an asthma attack an asthma
attack
i tend to identify as when my medication
doesn't work it's
very very very bad and really scary and
i've had two asthma attacks in the hotel
room they really are awful
um and after i had my first asthma
attack
and you can call the nurses 24 hours for
help with anything with any kind of
condition for anyone who would go
through this that has any kind of
illness um i did call them and ask if
there was any way for me to be moved
anywhere that has a balcony
and uh or even a window that i could
open
and the answer was ultimately no um so
you know while i had access to nurses
every day
they were just like well if you need a
prescription to get more medication you
can
and they could help me with that but i
had all the medication i needed like i
said i knew coming into this that it
would be
pretty sucky for me but i didn't expect
it to be quite this bad ultimately
so yeah they'd call and i'd be like okay
my ass was really terrible right now
um is there anything i can do and they
were very sympathetic and kind but
the answer is ultimately that they can't
do anything for you which
sucks real bad um it's not their fault
and i don't blame them
but i would think for anyone who is a
fair amount older than me
that i would advise you just not do this
like
it uh yeah the lack of fresh air for
anyone who has probably
a severe kind of respiratory respiratory
illness i'm sure there are other
illnesses that pertain to like not
having fresh air being a problem as well
but i can only speak to the one that i
have obviously that it yeah it's the
worst that it's been
probably in my entire life locked in
this room for two weeks with no fresh
air so
worse than i expected even though i
expected bad it for me mentally has been
the hardest part i've been so
frustrated and very like just
downtrodden
by that specifically by constantly not
being able to breathe and again
i hope that i don't sound like i'm being
some um privileged complainer
i totally recognize that this is a
choice that i made and that i knew
and that i'm incredibly lucky to be home
to see
my big sister and to become an aunt and
to see my whole family like i'm
so [ __ ] excited to get outside and
and have that i'm gonna be so happy you
know
um and then i could afford this but i
it's not something that i want to
gloss over because of that because other
people who have asperger will also go
through this and will have the same
thing
so yes it was that was the only tough
part for my mental health really was
it just made me really [ __ ] miserable
just like oh i wake up again and i can't
breathe
cool another day of not being able to
breathe great okay so that yes that got
very hard for me
and um i had to halt some of my workouts
because of that too because i get
asthma from working out that's very
common um so i just had to kind of
lighten those a little bit so that was
definitely something that was tougher
than i thought it would be on me
mentally i didn't realize how
frustrated i would be by that as someone
who
generally is cool with everything very
easygoing and like cool whatever i don't
care that's fine
um yeah it's uh i was fine in the
lockdown last year you know
like being stuck inside my tiny
apartment in la for
eight months completely alone didn't
really bother me overall because i had
windows so in here much much much harder
but that's that's my main downside
there's a little bit of dirt just kind
of started to annoy me
i think in large part because it leaned
into my concerns with having asked me
that
all the time so it's it's for the
greater good but it is still something
that you know regardless of being aware
of all of those things was
very tough to deal with mentally is
is just stupid thing about having asthma
is knowing that your own body is trying
to suffocate you from the inside out too
it's just like can you just [ __ ]
leave me alone because it's just your
own [ __ ] chest doing it to you
there were also some moments where
um my internet connection dropped
infrequently not something that was
hugely prohibitive for me just a thing
to note for anyone going through this
largely the internet in this hotel was
wonderful i had 200 up to 200 down i was
able to stream
i was able to upload youtube videos it
was it was great um i was able to work
have video calls all that good stuff
just a couple of hiccups nothing major
yeah the only other thing is there are a
couple of times where they forgot to
bring me food they
didn't bring me lunch on two separate
days
very weird but i wasn't really worried
about it because i
i frankly ate way too much while i was
in here anyway because i think i liked
the routine of like the food arrives at
this time and you have an activity at
this time but those are the only
real major negatives that that i felt um
i will also say i have a beautiful view
here like an absolutely beautiful view
so like i can show you now this is
darling harbour in sydney and it is
lovely
um watching the sunrise come over that
every day it was beautiful it was it was
so nice
so no real downside there i'm probably
gonna miss seeing the sunrise if
anything it's been it's been
lovely i did also end up in the uh
end of this whole thing just
got way more alcohol than i would have
expected like
i got beer delivered from a friend and
then the hotel just kept delivering me
like wine and stuff some of those i did
opt into but they gave me more than i
asked for
by a lot and i got a bunch of cider that
was definitely a thing ended up
delivering a lot more alcohol than i
thought and i yeah i did successfully
get some food delivered through ubereats
but overall you know a totally fine
experience uh
nothing extremely outlying like i feel
like there were more positives than i
expected which is that it went past
really fast and um i wasn't bored at all
and i was able to work out i just
cleared some stuff here and had a
perfect vr
setup space internet was strong and
solid and the food was actually really
good
obviously the downside being the asthma
not really being able to
clean in any way that i would have liked
to um
i think i said you can take your sheets
and put them outside and order new
sheets and all that stuff so you can do
laundry for your sheets and your towels
but
that's the extent of that really i i've
worn the same clothes intentionally over
and over again though this i realized i
got
some food on so we're gonna need to wash
that as soon as we get out of here but
yeah that's pretty much it just kind of
wanted to go over
sort of what this was like fill in any
information that i feel like would be
helpful to people who might go through
it but i don't think i have anything
else to add so yeah please do let me
know if you have any questions i will
help out as much as i can
um with anyone who might have questions
and
yeah i'm really excited to get to see my
family
it is a very exciting time i don't know
what my internet connection is going to
be like as soon as i leave here
so i don't know what's going to happen
to streams or uploads
now between my mom and my dad's houses
which i assume will have different
speeds i don't know but um
i'll do my best and i'll keep everyone
updated where i can
thank you for watching i will see you
guys next time bye